[Musique]
alors l effet pas chroniqueuse mais je
passerais bien un petit moment avec
kelly pascal a l'air super sympa et un
mix très très bien c'est une espèce de
thriller amoureux avec un couple qui
attend des amis pour dîner ses amis
n'arrivent pas par langnau amis on parle
de nous on se rend compte que coke que
tout notre mariage est basé sur du
mensonge
il ya des moments où je suis très cruel
avec ma femme et ça généralement le
public aime terme
la perruche avec barbara schulz et riels
mallette
je laisse à la londe
dans dix ans je serai à la la land star
[Musique]
dans la vie déjà il ya de quoi faire
quand il veut gagner je te défie quand
tu veux enfin duo toi et moi